Lawrence starts off this hour in
Charleston South Carolina
hey Lawrence how are you hey Dave
pleasure to speak with you you calling
in because I graduated recently from
dental school in 2014 have about three
hundred nine thousand dollars in dental
school debt and I have a hundred
thousand dollars in savings a monthly
income between twelve and sixteen
thousand expenses fixed expenses each
month around seven seven thousand Kay
and what I'm trying to figure out how do
you have seven thousand dollars and
fixed expenses if you just got out of
dental school oh well it was 2014 I'm
talking about my mortgage my student
loans cars that's oh so you and I bought
a bunch of crap even though you were
$300,000 in debt
well I have a car and neither the house
so what kind of car you got I Drive a
Lexus GX no okay and it's new yeah two
years ago wasn't it when you bought it
okay yes sir alright well you needed a
car you need that one okay I'm back with
you you got a mess on your hands so what
are you gonna do about it degree what
are you gonna do I disagree I was
calling because I mean I've got a lot in
savings and I've got a lot of student
debt and at the same time I'm trying to
figure out you know should I spend more
should I take what's in my students you
know in my savings and pay towards my
debt what how much should I have in my
savings where you know where do I go
from here don't you
okay well I think it's safe to say you
tried to borrow your way into prosperity
and you figured out that plan doesn't
work yes sir
and so the opposite direction is
obviously the plan that gets you to
prosperity
meaning wealth the fastest yeah because
if you had your income and no payments
oh my goodness you'd be wealthy so fast
that it be unbelievable right correct
yeah so that's where we might audacity
my capacity to save each month is about
six to seven thousand dollars after I
paid you know all of my other expenses
okay and so what is your household
income a year household income is
probably about 260 okay all right cool
okay and you have 309 and how much in
nan student loan nan mortgage debt just
the cars I'm student just the cars and
what do you owe on them currently I
think the GX is about $29,000 mm-hmm
each the other car is a lease that cost
me about 400 a month what would it take
to pay it off probably twenty four
thousand yeah yeah okay so 50 60 grand
of your hundred makes you car payment
debt-free then all we have left is
mortgages I mean then all we have left
is student loans I'm sorry student loans
yeah and the other thing is here's what
happens to you Doc's we call it doc itís
okay and you have a classic case of doc
itis and that is is that you are
absolutely wonderful at delaying
pleasure to win and so what happens is
you go to school you know four or five
years longer than everybody else right
and you make no money while all your
buddies are out there making money they
graduate with a BA and they're going
right or BS or they're going or they
came out of high school and they started
a technology company and they're going
man and you're looking around these
people are all making money you're still
in school
you're still in its correct but the goal
is to be a doc the goals will be a
dentist right DDS man we got to get that
thing we're after in game all right
chasing the goal and you're you're
delaying pleasure for a greater good if
I can just get through this thing then
I'm gonna make Bank and it'll all be
okay all right
and you emotionally are in that sense
you're emotionally very very mature and
far beyond the average cat walking
around I'm bragging on you because
here's what happens it's almost as if
you
holding your breath and as soon as you
graduate and pass your boards and get
your job it's like you have this exhale
of lifestyle and even though you're
three hundred and nine thousand dollars
in debt you go buy two cars and a house
instantaneously and all the house was in
the last year I just recently well
you've still you're still exhaling then
okay do you get moment you've been
delaying pleasure delaying pleasure to
laying pleasure and instead of staying
with that a little bit longer and
knocking off the 309 you preempted your
ability you neutered your ability to to
get at the 309 by adding all these other
payments and lifestyle correct and so if
you want to get to wealth the fastest
thing you can do is go back to the pain
of living like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
that wasn't the phrase you used when you
were in dental school when you were in
undergrad heading towards dental school
but it's what you were thinking I'm
gonna pay a price now so that I win
later yes sir and you have that
emotional capacity and maturity we know
that because you're a DBS you couldn't
got in there if you didn't have that I
want you to tap into that and get your
wife on board to tap into that I don't
want y'all cut your lifestyle to nothing
I don't want to hear about your $260,000
income and you going on vacation because
you are a broke dentist you have three
hundred and nine thousand dollars worth
of net and you're either gonna screw
around with this debt for the next
decade and be a classic broke dentist or
you're gonna knock it out in the next
two and a half or three years pay off
the cars today hold a small emergency
fund very small like five thousand bucks
in your case usually we say a thousand
but crap you make a quarter million
dollars a year so we'll make it five
thousand bucks and then you guys get
after that student loan debt no I mean
don't buy anything no you don't get to
go out to eat you don't have time you're
paying on debt scorched-earth lifestyle
and if you can't do that and sell then
sell your house but I don't think you
got to sell your house I don't think you
got to sell your cars to think you have
a 360 thousand dollar income but you
need to stop investing no no more
investing no more saving we're going to
beat the snot out of $309,000 if you do
that the numbers say you'll be debt-free
in less than three years so would be
with the best advantage at this point
then to feed a pay off pay off the car
yes
and then today just get that monthly
cash flow up so that I can get back to
paying off the debt and get on a budget
that's tighter than the one you're
living on yes okay cuz a hundred you
said six or seven thousand dollars a
month I need you at about nine thousand
a month going towards that nine thousand
dollars into three hundred thousand gets
you there in 31 months thirty two months
not counting interest and that puts you
on a three-year schedule that's what I
want you on that's the math I was just
doing but I mean that's only 120
thousand dollars a year you make 260 so
you cry me a river'
about your lifestyle do this in three
years you can do it you can do it live
like no one else no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time though but it
yields a harvest of righteousness that's
from the Bible for those of you don't
know this is the Dave Ramsey show